you you perceive symptoms of an illness
as a message from your body that
something needs attention right um it's
a brilliant book but what i can tell you
most of the time
when i look at people who have had
different types of cancers right is that
um there's a big
self-sacrifice in the cancer personality
types where they tend they not always
those we don't there's not all or never
but on a spectrum right bell curve
spectrum
a lot of people with cancer
put themselves last or they've become
invisible or they've deferred they don't
have a sense of internal sense of agency
and
um the cancer comes in as an opportunity
an opportunity for them to like take
charge of their healing right i think
probably the best example of that is a
woman named chris carr who write crazy
sexy cancer um and she basically talks
about how she became the ceo of her
health and she talks about how
you know all the doctors said you know
lung cancer and all this stuff now
doctor said she had this much time to
live and she's like outpaced all of them
by like decades plus right she's chris
carr is an incredible human being um
and you know she did all the work that i
just suggested and she still has it in
her body but she's living with it she's
living in an outmostly alkaline state
and she's doing her emotional work but
each l each chronic illness has a
different purpose right if you think
about diabetes not type one but type two
diabetes and pre-diabetes i would ask
you like what's not sweet about your
life
right what's like what's missing because
you know sugar is an analgesic that
numbs pain um people focus on sugar and
dopamine but really the analgesia and
the pain numbing that's really important
or like if you have endometriosis or
something like that it's like
what's not being born through you right
like things like that because you want
to look at that level it's not the only
level that you want to look at but you
want to look through those levels
to understand like there's a there's
more going on here than like an iso and
itis or an osis or whatever right
there's there's more happening here than
just the diagnosis itself does that make
sense
absolutely absolutely definitely very
lewis hey like you know looking at like
where it's coming if you you know you
can't speak it's like what are you not
saying and if you have a sore throat
it's like sorry if you have a sore
throat it's like what are you not saying
things like that it's like looking at
the body as um
a road map like to kind of like leading
you to the space she had a huge data set
by the way she worked with tens of
thousands of people i mean there's a
reason why you can hear your life sold
like 40 50 million copies right like
yeah i mean i have it on my bookshelf
it's just a tiny little book but it's
basically like you know you put it you
look up your um symptom and then it
gives you a suggestion and i hate it
every time i'm like
and louise is a friend of mine before
she passed i was so sad but from the
grave i'm like goddamn about the weed
like ah you're so right you know stop it
you know
it's so simple right i mean like life
generally i mean i've said this a few
times lately i tend to
repeat a thought in my head until it's
been vetted out until i come to some
sort of conclusion on it but um that
life is life is like really simple
because it's kind of all information
about ourselves that's right everything
through everything yeah through
everything and so but yet it's
complicated because we can't see
ourselves yes so it's kind of like my
friend said um her and her daughter were
having a conversation she's like her
daughter's really pretty spiritual for
her age for sure she's just like 12. um
but she was talking to her daughter
about insecurity and she goes mom she's
like
you don't you can't you can't see
yourself in 3d
you don't know how you move and how you
look and she's like you only see
yourself in 2d and i'm like oh my god
that's so brilliant like found
right
you never like we never see ourselves in
3d to know how we navigate the world and
how we look and how we feel and you know
so um
anyway is that it's all information
about us and that we need other people
in other situations call it a dis-ease
call it a person a relationship a
promotion a firing a breakup whatever it
is true love we need all these things to
see ourselves because we can't see
ourselves like it has to continue to be
reflected back through all these other
mediums yeah a hundred percent and i
think i think the beauty in it yeah i
wanna because i i
i think one of my favorite topics to
talk about is relationships because
they're so
um
complicated and funny if you look at it
a certain way but also so painful and
awful but also so beautiful and amazing
um and i think one of the biggest
misnomers is that people think that you
know for example in a relationship i
just heard this with a client like the
other day you know um
they were dating this woman was dating
this guy and they were getting closer
and closer and closer and taking their
time and then they you know slept
together and then he like had a freak
out and was like oh my god i just
realized all this stuff is coming up and
i have to go do the work on my own and
i'm like amateur move nope that's not
how it works because the purpose of
relationship like you get traumatizing
relationship
it's the vessel for healing too right
you don't heal on your own so this whole
idea to love myself before i get into a
relationship is nonsense avoidant
[ __ ]
right oh my god preach and rip go on a
tangent i'm ready for it i'm here
because yeah because the healing is
through the relationship right it's
through the relationship and so that
i've said this a bunch i think it's so
important you know obviously what's the
purpose of relationship well in in in
evolutionary biology it's obviously
procreation and safety in numbers right
for mammals we get along in numbers
right and then you talk about okay
then we're going to like maybe help each
other like amplify our purpose and like
each of us will have a bigger future
together right cool awesome
um okay romance cool passion cool check
awesome we got all the good stuff maybe
shared financial burdens cool awesome
right great awesome
but the real juice in a relationship is
twofold one is to be a caretaker and i
use that word intentionally if you don't
like the fact that i'm using this word
because some people look like caretaker
oh my god
look up the definition before you go
further okay
to become a caretaker of each other's
traumatic parts right that is a not the
therapist not a mom not a dad but to
understand at like a very profound level
what someone's pain is like what is
their pain
and then to intentionally do [ __ ] to
help that not happen and to
like help to like make it better for
that person in that area and to have
that be mutually reciprocal so some
people will say to me mastin that's
crazy i do that but i'm in the
relationship with a narcissist and they
don't do that i'm like no you're not
getting it it has to be reciprocal right
it can't just be one way okay so if you
by the way if you know that you're in a
relationship with a narcissist
what's your part in that get out of that
relationship okay like knock it off like
get out right
um but it's about having mutually
reciprocal regulations so that the
relationship becomes a place to regulate
and to feel better rather than a place
to escape from and avoid right it's like
the opposite of what we've been taught
so is this co-regulation versus
codependency yes exactly yes thank you
for saying that that's so accurately
clinical so i love that that's beautiful
they're your words my friend i know but
okay that's true okay but you said it
and okay yeah you said it and that's
really good you you just mirrored me
which is beautiful so that maybe that's
why i liked it so much but but so here's
the second part okay and so like one you
want to understand like okay this is
this person's trauma here's the things
that help them regulate and vice versa
and i'm feeling reciprocation here but
the second part and this is the hard
part okay and i think if i was like a
guardian angel
like i would set life up this way just
to be entertained by like the reality
show called earth right like because
there's just so many things happening
and it's just like that is what's
happening i think by the way it's just
like oh let's just
keeping up with earth let's just see how
it's going down there right i imagine
that there's people up there with
popcorn totally oh can you believe that
oh an idiot you know yeah totally so
silly they don't see it yeah totally
totally
so so so this is what i think keeps the
guardian angels amused right is is um
most people
um will say
we shouldn't be together
because we want different things right
and that
danica is an also an amateur move okay
the reason why you shouldn't be together
is because you don't know how to do
different things
together
and there's a big difference because
it's the things we have in common that
attract us to each other and it's our
differences that grow us
right
um and so knowing how to be different
and together is like the master skill
in relationship and it is so
hard because the way the world works is
we pull in our mirror who has something
that we're missing
and that initially makes it very
exciting for us but over time it will
disregulate us
because it starts to repeat old patterns
unless we learn differentiation which is
how can i be my full self and my
different self and really embody what
i'm learning from this other person
into my own being so that they're
they're a place where i can go to
regulate a place where i go to be safe
and awesome but i have my own life my
own boundaries my own purpose and we are
different together and the key skill set
in that
is knowing how to navigate the tension
of being different
and most people have no clue how to do
that because all these automatic
patterns are coming up um and
it is beautiful on the other side of
that kind of um
that kind of growth because you know you
resolve things from childhood you
amplify your purpose but then you can
like be your own self and neither party
has to collapse because usually if one
party takes up all the space another
party that's kind of collapsing in a
relationship right and the most ideal
relationship is both parties are like
the light both parties it's kind of like
in chemistry they're called eczemas uh
noble gases where they're balanced right
they're not trying to attract a negative
or a positive like you know negative and
positive come together noble gases or
eczema are completely balanced and they
don't attract negatives or positive
because they're balanced and the only
way for like a noble gas like neon to be
able to merge another noble gas is they
have to become light together right
which is why neon signs light up right
because they're temporarily emerging
so to me it's like an eczema vibe where
it's like for us to actually be together
we both have to step into our light and
that's like beautiful
yeah i think so too right i want art
made out of that yeah totally needs to
become art yeah i'm actually going to
get here regulate uh neon sign which is
kind of cheesy but because it's like
what it means beneath what it says it's
going to say manifesting magic but it's
neon and the neon represents kind of
eczemas which is like basically two
balanced beings coming together to make
light which i think is like so cool you
know oh cool and they have to be like
that's beautiful